so the topic today is on nutrient dense
foods there are certain nutrients that
are very easy to get and some
that are very very difficult probably
out of all the nutrients the one that is
the most difficult
is vitamin d in fact it's next to
impossible
to get the vitamin d that you need from
foods
this is why we have the sun right now
probably one of the vitamins
that is the easiest to get is probably
vitamin k1
not k2 but vitamin k1 which is has
anti-clotting factors
and i would say b6 is pretty easy to get
to it's in
so many different foods but the problem
is a requirement for potassium is so
high we need 4 700 milligrams
that that's another one that's difficult
to get unless you're consuming
a lot of vegetables minimally seven
cups now you can also get potassium from
meats as well
so you want to include all of your foods
to figure out your potassium levels
magnesium is another one that a lot of
people are deficient in
but if you're consuming enough
vegetables you're going to get magnesium
but magnesium is another mineral that a
lot of people are deficient in
and it's a very necessary mineral to act
as a cofactor for
a lot of different chemical reactions in
the body
all right now let's talk about vitamin a
this is a very confusing topic
because you'll see certain videos in
blog
articles on vitamin a is in
spinach it's in kale you have to realize
that is a pre vitamin a
it's not the actual bioavailable active
form of vitamin a called retinol
it's mainly in a beta-carotene form
which is a precursor so you have to
convert it
and rarely does anyone get any
significant amount of
retinol from consuming vegetables
because number one
the conversion factor is so low and on
top of that 45
of the population has a mutation with
their genes
that doesn't allow them to convert the
pre-vitamin a
to the active form of vitamin a and one
of the best sources of
active retinol would be in organ meats
it would be in egg yolks now the next
one i want to talk about
is omega-3 fatty acids another one that
is a bit difficult to get
unless you're consuming fatty fish organ
meats
grass-fed animal products now you can
get
omega-3 fatty acids in algae
and seafood etc but the precursor to
the omega-3 fatty acid dha is
something called ala which is in walnuts
it's in other plants it's in certain
seeds
but the conversion factor is very very
small so even though ala
is an omega-3 fatty acids it's kind of
like a precursor
it's not the actual important dha
omega-3 fatty acid itself now the next
set of
nutrients i want to talk about is trace
minerals many many many
people are deficient in trace minerals
simply because unless you're consuming
food from the sea or sea
kelp or shellfish you're not going to
get a lot of trace minerals
however there are a good amount of trace
minerals and organ meats
as we kind of go through this list and
talk about what foods
have certain key nutrients that will
give you
a really good idea on what you should be
eating or what diet you should be on
and then we get to the topic of iron you
have
heme iron which is a bio-available iron
which is in animal products
and then you have non-heme iron which
are in
vegetables and plants like spinach for
example
which is not very available to you
so the most bioavailable iron
is from animal products
so as you can see as we're going in the
list
a perfect diet would be a combination of
plant foods
and animal foods and let's not forget
b12
b12 is in animal products
now plants do give us a good amount of
vitamin c
and you can get a good amount of vitamin
c from berries like blueberries
blackberries
which have a low glycemic index now many
people are trying to get their vitamin c
from fruit the problem is that there's
just too much sugar and fruit
and the fruit nowadays has been grown
with
high levels of sugar carbohydrates so
we're not going to recommend that but
you can get a good amount of vitamin c
from vegetables which are low in sugar
even though
they're high in carbohydrate but a lot
of that carbohydrate is
fiber which does not affect your blood
sugars now even though
antioxidants and phytonutrients that are
in our foods are not classified as
essential
nutrients i'm going to add this to the
list simply because there's so many
benefits
of these phytonutrients for example
the phytonutrients in garlic anti-cancer
antimicrobial are off the charts
so a lot of spices and herbs and
classes of vegetables like cruciferous
give you additional nutrients like
phytonutrients
that go way beyond just the essential
nutrients that most people think with
so if we take a look at the foods that
are most nutrient dense
at the top of the list we have organ
meats
grass-fed liver of course grass-fed
heart and brains
are loaded with bioavailable nutrients
so you don't need much of it
but a little bit on a regular basis
would be very very helpful
plus vitamin k2 which i haven't really
talked about
is in organ meats it's in fatty meats
it's in egg yolks it's in grass-fed
dairy
and then we get shellfish which not only
has the omega-3 fatty acids
but it's loaded with trace minerals and
vitamins and minerals
salmon great source of omega-3 fatty
acids
plus it has trace minerals and a great
source of protein as well
and then before we have cruciferous
vegetables so we have
great amounts of phytonutrients that are
anti-cancer
but we also have potassium magnesium
trace minerals vitamin c but we're not
getting
retinol from cruciferous vegetables
number five i put in here
salads or leafy greens for your
potassium
and your magnesium plus it has vitamin c
and a lot of other
great nutrients as well a lot of the b
vitamins as well
number six grass-fed meats have a really
good spectrum of nutrients
a great diversity of b vitamins and
minerals
and even antioxidants and then we get to
the topic of
eggs now the protein in eggs is very
different than the protein you would get
from meat we're dealing with an
embryo which gives you very unique types
of nutrients
versus animal muscle protein but the egg
yolk is loaded with
the active form of vitamin a which is
retinol the egg has a
great balance of nutrients pretty much
every nutrient
except vitamin c it may have a small
amount of vitamin c but
nothing significant but the egg yolk has
choline which prevents the fatty liver
helps your nervous system it has
virtually all the fat soluble vitamins
including k2 so we definitely don't want
to neglect the egg
i already mentioned fruits have too much
sugar potatoes
actually have a good amount of potassium
and other nutrients like vitamin c but
they're high in
starch so even though it may have some
nutrients i'm not going to add that to
the list
now even though grains have certain
nutrients okay like the b vitamins
they are high in phytates which block
certain trace minerals so they have
properties of anti-nutrients and plus
they are
also high in carbs there are certain
vegetables that are high in oxalates
like spinach for example and rhubarb
which will block
calcium and they can also add a lot of
other problems to your life like they
can give you
arthritic pains as well as kidney stones
so even though spinach and swiss chard
has
a lot of nutrients it also has
anti-nutrients as well
and other compounds like tannins in
tea and coffee have factors that deplete
nutrients as well
but really only if you're consuming
large quantities in them so if you're
drinking tea all day long and coffee
it could be depleting a lot of key
nutrients unless you put those
back in all right guys so there you have
it the seven
most nutrient-dense foods
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call and get some help